Військові приготування - у Росії, Україні та НАТО.
І дискусії на всіх рівнях про те, як усе ж таки уникнути реальної ескалації на українському кордоні.
Буквально минулого тижня Євросоюз застеріг Кремль щодо жорстких санкцій у разі вторгнення в Україну.
Однак на ситуацію це поки ніяк не вплинуло.
Навпаки, Москва тепер озвучила свої умови для миру.
Спершу вустами дипломатів, а потім особисто Володимира Путіна.
Нам потрібні довгострокові гарантії з юридичними зобов'язаннями.
Але ж ми з вами знаємо: і цьому не можна вірити. Жодним юридичним гарантіям.
Тому що Сполучені Штати легко виходять із будь-яких міжнародних договорів,
які їм з тієї чи іншої причини стають нецікавими.
Вимоги Москва висунула наприкінці минулого тижня у формі двох проєктів договорів - зі США та НАТО - про так звані "гарантії безпеки".
Суть вимог - Україну не можна приймати в НАТО,
а сам Північноатлантичний Альянс має вивести всі свої озброєння з регіону колишнього СРСР
та відмовитися від проведення навчань на цих територіях.
До того протягом кількох тижнів Росія стягувала свої підрозділи до кордону з Україною.
Перекидання російських військових, як упевнені в Альянсі, триває й досі.
У НАТО заявляють, що хочуть діалогу з Москвою.
При цьому путінські вимоги щодо невступу України в Альянс категорично відкидають.
Ми виступаємо за суверенітет та територіальну цілісність України,
а також за право України обирати власний шлях. Епоха сфер впливу закінчилася.
У самій Україні до загрози вторгнення поставилися дуже серйозно.
На цих кадрах видно, як у Сумській області укріплюють кордон протитанковими ровами та валами.
Тим часом український президент Зеленський запропонував Путіну зустрітися в будь-якому форматі.
Але водночас нагадав Брюсселю про амбіції Києва щодо вступу в НАТО
і заявив, що чекає на конкретні терміни вже у 2022 році.
Усі ми не можемо прийняти тезу, яка теж дуже популярна, про ЄС через 30 років, а НАТО колись там років через 50.
Кремль уже вдруге цього року перекидає сотні тисяч військових та важку техніку до своїх західних кордонів.
Чого насправді домагається Путін? Ось що думають з цього приводу німецькі експерти.
Це типове перекручування причин і наслідків, яке ми спостерігаємо роками з боку російського керівництва.
Це цілеспрямована ескалація і це вже не вперше.
Москва за допомогою цього нагнітання ескалації розраховує отримати стратегічні, вирішальні переваги щодо США та НАТО.
На думку експерта Ебергарда Шнайдера, російський президент своїми вимогами сам себе загнав у пастку.
Путін знає, що США та НАТО не можуть виконати цих умов.
Він також не може кожні пів року перекидати війська туди-сюди, оскільки рано чи пізно все це виглядатиме неправдоподібно.
Вступ України в НАТО - це не тільки неактуально, але й неймовірно доти,
доки Київ не відмовиться від Криму та територій, зайнятих сепаратистами, назавжди.
Багато німецьких експертів вважають, що запропонований договір неможливо обговорювати всерйоз, проте діалог з Москвою необхідний.
Треба спробувати отримати від російської сторони пропозиції, які можна було б обговорювати.
Обидва проєкти договорів у такому вигляді для обговорення неприйнятні.
Зрозуміло, це мета переговорів, яку ставить собі Росія.
Але в подібних переговорах має бути: ми хочемо це і ми дамо вам за це те і те.
Мають бути можливості для компромісу. Поки що їх не видно.
Занепокоєння діями Москви присутнє у всіх кінцях Європи, як видно з коментарів у ЗМІ.
Путін переконаний, що Захід не виявляє до нього, спадкоємця російського царя,
належної поваги і поводиться зневажливо.
Він також упевнений, що Росія оточена ворогами.
А тому для нього напад на Україну - це акт самооборони.
Він не розглядає Україну як державу, яка зі страху перед Росією робить усе для свого захисту.
Він бачить її лише як маріонетку в руках американців.
У довгостроковій перспективі ЄС і НАТО потребують діалогу з Росією.
Сьогоднішній крижаний фронт руйнує потенційно важливе політичне співробітництво.
Росії також потрібні кращі відносини із Заходом - не в останню чергу з огляду на економіку.
Немає простих відповідей, але говорити з росіянами точно не завадить.
Проєкт угоди більше схожий на ультиматум, ніж на документ, який міг би стати відправною точкою для переговорів.
Крім того, цей документ був представлений у стилі, який світова дипломатія не бачила з часів Гітлера.
Що викликає у цьому зверненні особливу тривогу?
По суті, Путін пропонує в одному простому тексті поділити сфери впливу в Європі.
Держсекретар США Ентоні Блінкен заявив, що деякі з пропозицій Росії щодо гарантій безпеки явно не можуть бути прийняті Вашингтоном.
У той самий час є й моменти, щодо яких є сенс вести діалог.
За словами Блінкена, цей діалог може розпочатися вже на початку наступного року.
Однак він можливий лише за умови деескалації біля кордонів України
та координації з європейськими союзниками та партнерами.
Крім того, нової зустрічі президентів Байдена з Путіним поки що не планується.
Тим часом, як повідомили 22 грудня ЗМІ з посиланням на обізнаних дипломатів в Альянсі,
останніми днями НАТО привела свої сили швидкого реагування в Європі
чисельністю 40 тисяч військовослужбовців у підвищену бойову готовність.